es ist ein videoclip der wirklich
sprachlos macht in den polizisten von
einem abgeschobenen afghan aufs übelste
beschimpft und bedroht werden kurz zum
hintergrund das video hat ein afghane
aufgenommen der vor vier jahren nach
afghanistan abgeschoben worden ist in
deutschland ein unterwelt könig droht er
als abgeschobener jetzt mit polizei
morden afghanen die auf der abschiebe
liste stehen sollen in seinem auftrag in
deutschland vergewaltigen und töten wird
liegt das pro video vor wir haben lange
überlegt ob und was wir ihnen daraus
zeigen aber wir meinen sie sollen sie in
welcher schamlosigkeit und aggressivität
der deutschen polizei gedroht wird
so diese video gilt man die polizei
frankfurt polizei offenbach polizei
ratingen und polizei usingen und des
weiteren auch an die sek die ja kleine
[ __ ] wir so ein von ihr kleiner
bastard wiener habt ihr kleines netz
dieser ganze durchsuchung in dieser
ganze faxen was er macht erreicht damit
ist ihr kleiner posten hat mich
abgeschoben wie ihr kleiner [ __ ] ja
ihr nutzen kinder ihr [ __ ] hört
damit auch sonst geschwister bei gott
ich habe genug afghanen in frankfurt und
umgebung die sind auf der abschussliste
und die sind zu allem bereit und ich
fand einen kunden ich schwöre bei gott
an eurem hat hängen ich werde der erste
sein der bullen tötet ohne 2 sek beamten
töteten
2008 geht dann werde ich dafür sorgen
dass ich 100 auf ghana die auf der
abschussliste setzen die werde ich auch
vorschau verziehen und unsere mutter
[ __ ] ich werde so viele tötens durch
bis zum gehtnichtmehr ich bin heute noch
breit nach wollte man zu kommen wo ich
mich in boston an vorlegen werde eure
wohnung absuchen
ich bin raus sind wo ihr wohnt wo er
arbeitet und ich weiss ahlen es sind
afghane auf ruhig jetzt sind bissig
stöger unterstrich bei gott das ist kein
scherz das ist kein facebook ist keine
landung das wort todes erster pass tagen
wenn anderes möbel dann habe ich wohl
straße machen wo es langgeht
wie gesagt das sind drastische worte
aber wir wollten dass sie sich selbst
ein bild machen können ja ein mann der
die polizei wirklich aufs übelste
beleidigt und auch ankündigt ausgewählte
polizisten zu töten wer ist das
überhaupt und das hier sind die
bekannten fakten zu den abgeschobenen
unterwelt könig sein name ist seine amar
die 35 jahre alt geboren in kabul
insgesamt stellte er drei asylanträge
den ersten im oktober 2000 alle werden
abgelehnt und häufig benutzte dabei
nicht sein richtigen namen sondern alias
namen zum beispiel nennt er sich josi
alvarez oder augustin hernandez aktuell
soll er sich in der türkei aufhalten und
wie gefährlich dieser mann ist zeigt ein
blick auf seine strafakte insgesamt 30
straftaten sind darauf aufgelistet
räuberische erpressungen bedrohung
betrug unterschlagung vergewaltigung
sexuelle nötigungen besonders schwerer
diebstahl gefährliche körperverletzung
dokumentenfälschungen gewerbsmäßige
hehlerei und während seiner 17 jahre in
deutschland soll sich sagen was
ausschließlich mit rauschgifthandel und
schutzgeld erpressung verdient haben bei
uns im studio ist rainer wendt der ist
der bundesvorsitzende der deutschen
polizeigewerkschaft
guten morgen herr wendt halogen- und
morgen ja leere worte oder
ernstzunehmenden drohungen zunächst
einmal muss man ja feststellen wenn es
je eine abschiebung gegeben hat die
gerechtfertigt gewesen ist dann war es
dieser abschiebung befragt wie es nur
warum das 17 jahre gedauert hat und erst
mal so eine lange latte von straftaten
begehen muss und die nächste frage die
sich bei vielen sicherlich anschließt
ist er hat er ist ja nicht alleine
gewesen hatte ein umfeld und was ist
eigentlich mit seinen mit seinen
gesinnungsgenossen sind die alle noch
hier und wenn ja warum das ist ja die
nächste frage denn von denen geht ja
auch eine gefahr aus aber um ihre frage
zu beantworten
das muss man schon ernst nehmen und das
wird auch ernst genommen das heißt die
sicherheitsbehörde sind alarmiert und
werden in aller ruhe das analysieren da
ist viel maulheldentum dabei bekannten
beleidigungen für die
sicherheitsbehörden die kennt man bei
jeder festnahme bei jedem
gerichtsprozess findet so etwas stadt
aber sind auch sehr präzise
ankündigungen und man muss ja sagen
damit setzt er sich auch selber unter
handlungsdruck das heißt er hat ja auch
eine autorität zu verlieren und in
diesem milieu ist sind ja begriffe wie
autoritäre und und manneskraft wenn man
so will von großer bedeutung und wenn er
wenn da jetzt nichts passiert wird er
diese autorität eingebüßt die sagen es
ist das sehr präzise er spricht sogar
polizisten in einzelnen städten an wie
schützen sie diese polizisten diese
beamten jetzt zunächst einmal wird es
darum gehen und genau das wird
stattfinden dass die sicherheitsbehörden
die zuständigen landeskriminalämter
gefährdungsanalysen erstellen und eine
wirkliche gefahrenprognose auch für
jeden einzelnen dieser angesprochenen
kollegen erstellen wird und dann auch
die entsprechenden schutzmaßnahmen
notfalls ergreifend wird dass das nicht
öffentlich stattfindet sowohl die
gefährdungsanalyse als auch die
schutzmaßnahmen liegt auf der hand wie
gehen sie jetzt damit um werden
bestimmte personen überwacht er spricht
er in dem video davon dass er afghanen
aufforderte tätig zu werden sie können
davon ausgehen dass es immer verdeckte
und auch offene operation gibt das heißt
dieses milieu erfreut sich sowieso einen
großen beliebtheit der polizeilichen
aufmerksamkeit das wissen wir aus
nordrhein westfalen aus berlin aus allen
anderen ländern dass in diesem milieu
die polizei hochwasserdamm ist übrigens
nicht nur die polizei sondern
fachübergreifend auch mit anderen
behörden dieses milieu ständig unter
druck gehalten wird da haben wir in der
tat viel zu lange hin nicht hingeschaut
aber jetzt wird mit grossem druck auf
diese organisation und auf diese banden
einfluss genommen und es wird auch
häufig mit mit razzien mit festnahmen
auf diese organisation eingewirkt leider
ist es so dass die möglichkeiten diese
typen die ja alle nicht nach deutschland
gehören auch aus deutschland
zurückzubringen einigermaßen
eingeschränkt sind in afghanistan jetzt
auf null gesunken wenn wir noch mal kurz
schauen über den man ist ja auch einiges
mehr bekannt nicht nur durch seine
strafakte ist er dem gehören bekannt
auch sonst ist ja kein beschriebenes
blatt seine ramadi ist der boss des
sogenannten lions kartells gegründet
wurde der club 2015 und steht in engem
kontakt zu den höchst umstrittenen
motorrad und rockerclubs hells angels
außerdem treten die mitglieder oft für
befreundete gruppierungen auf sogar
werbung machen sie auf ihrer homepage
dafür und darin kann man zwischen
verschiedenen
dienstleistungen wählen immobilien und
autoverkauf aber auch detektiv arbeiten
wie personen recherchen adresse
ermittlungen und observationen weiter
unten nachdem sicherheitsleistungen ist
dann auch von schuld eintreiben die rede
ja wie gefährlich sind diese lions
dieser lions kartell diese gruppierung
schließlich an wie viele andere auch
einzelne mitglieder haben dieses
sogenannte 1 prozent auf ihren kunden
stehen was darauf hindeutet dass sie
sozusagen stolz darauf sind outlaws zu
sein das heißt sich nicht an bestehendes
recht zu halten mit all diesen dingen
die bei diesen gruppierungen dazu
gehören strikte verweigerung der
zusammenarbeit mit der polizei mit
anderen sicherheitsbehörden hohes maß an
krimineller energie und an brutalität
aber auch vor allen dingen sehr
konspiratives vorgehen so öffentlich wie
das dort klingt ist das eigentliche
tatsächliche vorgehen dann natürlich
nicht da wird sehr konspirativ
vorgegangen und mit hoher brutalität das
zeigen ja immer wieder auch
auseinandersetzungen wenn es um gebiets
hoheiten geht der wird schnell
geschossen und dann wird klar gemacht
wer wo zuständig ist in
anführungsstrichen um dann diese
machtansprüche auch zu sichern die hells
angels sind ja teilweise verboten warum
kann das nicht auch mit so einem neuen
skandal passiert es werden viele chapter
und charter und wie die alle heißen
verboten aber wir sind im deutsche
vereinsrecht es werden immer wieder neue
gruppierungen gegründet unter
irgendwelchen fantasienamen als
eingetragene vereine und die zu
verbieten ist nach dem deutschen
vereinsrecht ausgesprochen schwierig das
ist grundsätzlich auch gut so dass die
vereine da geschützt sind und nicht
leicht verboten werden können die
sicherheit die die politik hat gemeinsam
mit den sicherheitsbehörden immer wieder
in hessen in nordrhein westfalen auch
hier in berlin solche gruppen verboten
und es ist eigentlich eine daueraufgabe
das zu tun sobald erkenntnisse da sind
die verbotsverfügung dann auch
gerichtsfest rechtfertigen wird ob
werden auch verbotsverfügungen
ausgesprochen das ist teil des konzeptes
rainer wendt vielen dank und wir wollen
stefan meier dazu holen heißt
parlamentarischer staatssekretär im
innenministerium guten morgen herr meier
wir aktuell saga die in der türkei
aufpassen wie garantiert die politik wie
garantieren sie dass so ein verbrecher
nicht mehr nach deutschland kommen kann
naja
ist ja mit einer nicht einreisesperre
wer haftet und ich gehe davon aus dass
auch gemeinsam mit den türkischen
sicherheitsbehörden intensiv vorsorge
getroffen wird das handy
wird nach deutschland einreisen kann
so so schrecklich dieser vorfall ist und
dieses video ist wirklich nicht nur
unappetitlich sondern es ist ein
höchster weise widerwärtig und und und
abstoßend aber das eben martin
abgeschoben wurde zeigt ja auch dass der
deutsche rechtsstaat funktioniert dass
er mit einer wiedereinreise sperre
belegt es zeigt neben auch das
konsequent gehandelt wurde in dem ihnen
klargemacht wird er hat in deutschland
nichts verloren und ich kann nur
versichern wir werden alles dafür tun
die deutschen sicherheitsbehörden
gemeinsam jetzt im konkreten fall mit
den mit den türkischen
sicherheitsbehörden dass die nicht in
der deutschen
boden betreten wird aber ja selbst einen
nicht deutschen boden betritt wir haben
ja in dem video gerade gesehen dass er
versucht von wenn er sich dort auch der
türkei aus beispielsweise aktionen zu
steuern wie kann man das verhindern
habe ich ja schon richtig gesagt man
muss dieses video mit sicherheit auf die
leichte schulter zu nehmen wäre falsch
weil eben natürlich da ist viel
rhetorik mit dabei die man vielleicht
auch etwas
beiseite schieben kann aber wie sie auch
schon erwähnt haben er nennt konkrete
dienststellen ernennt gerät sie
einheiten wie die wie das sek und vor
dem hintergrund muss natürlich jetzt
intensiv recherchiert werden mit wem
hatte er am aldi kontakt während seines
aufenthalts in deutschland wer ist von
diesen personen noch in deutschland wie
er ist möglicherweise gehört zu dieser
personengruppe tina maria konkret
adressiert spricht das heißt die
afghanische staatsangehörige und es muss
dann natürlich auch entsprechend
überprüft werden ob die rechtlichen
voraussetzungen gegeben sind
beispielsweise diese personen die
ausreisepflichtig sind in
gewahrsam zu nehmen da stehen das sind
die rechtlichen zugegebenermaßen relativ
hoch und leider ist es derzeit ja nicht
möglich abschiebungen nach afghanistan
durchzuführen bin aber auch der
überzeugung sobald die situation sich in
afghanistan wieder stabilisiert
müssten auch zumindest gefährte und
triebstrang afghanischen
staatsangehörigen die ausreisepflichtig
sind auch wieder nach afghanistan
abgeschoben werden also dieses video
wird mit sicherheit nicht auf die
leichte schulter genommen und es wird
zum einen natürlich die
erwähnte die von herrn wendt erwähnte
gefährdungsanalyse für die betroffenen
beamtinnen und beamten in den erwähnten
polizeidienststellen vorgenommen aber es
muss natürlich auch intensiv
recherchiert werden und detektiert
werden mit riemen hatte hermann die
kontakt und mit ihm hat er
möglicherweise auch heute noch
auch hier gibt es möglichkeiten dass man
dementsprechend nachgeht dass man die
kommunikation detektiert und
möglicherweise dann auch
geplanten anschlägen rechtzeitig auf die
schliche kommt und diese behindert herr
meier wie sieht das konkret aussehen uns
gerade schon kurz angesprochen die
sicherheit der polizisten wie schützen
sie
also es handelt sich hier natürlich
jetzt originäre zuständigkeit der länder
polizeien maria veener in seinem video
landes polizeidienststellen insbesondere
in hessen auf das sek in hessen also wir
arbeiten hier natürlich auch auf das
bundeskriminalamt intensiv mit den
hessischen sicherheitsbehörden
zusammen wenn es konkrete anhaltspunkte
gibt dass wunder dass das
polizeibeamtinnen und -beamte konkret
gefährdet sind da bin ich mir sehr
sicher dass die hessischen kolleginnen
und kollegen auch entsprechende
vorsorgemaßnahmen ergreifen um die
beamtinnen und beamte zu schützen soweit
ich jetzt dieses video kenne ich kenne
auch nur konkret ist es eine video
nennt er erwarte jetzt nicht einzelne
beamtinnen und beamte sondern belässt es
bei der benennung von einzelnen
polizeiinspektionen von einzelnen
dienststellen aber wie gesagt dieses
video wird nicht auf die leichte
schulter genommen ich bin mir sehr
sicher dass die zuständigen
polizeibehörden in hessen auf die
erforderlichen vorsorgemaßnahmen
ergreifen sie nach ihren erkenntnissen
ein einzelfall haben sie erkenntnisse
darüber wie viel abgeschobene straftäter
auf dem weg nach deutschland sind oder
versuchen aktionen gegen deutsche
behörden beispielsweise zu initiieren
also so schrecklich und zdf liegt dieses
video ist
nach handelt es sich jetzt hier um die
regel aber was da irgendwas ins team
rahmen der evakuierungsmaßnahmen
vor etwa einem monat habe deutschland
zurück gelangt sind wie schon in
deutschland waren auch genauso wie
hermann
asylanträge gestellt haben die abgelehnt
wurden dann auch diese personen
abgeschoben wurden und jetzt eben im
zuge der evakuierungsflüge wieder nach
deutschland eingereist sind was wir
jetzt als bundesministerium als konkrete
konsequenz gezogen haben ist dass wir
die sicherheitsüberprüfungen wieder
regulär vor der gegner an einreise nach
deutschland durch
wir ausstiegen amtes diese
sicherheitsüberprüfungen in der
hochphase der regierungen erst in
deutschland durchgeführt das war auch
sage ich ganz offen in dieser
extremsituation nicht anders machbar
aber wir sind jetzt wieder zudem regel
zustands zurückgekehrt das vor einer
geplanten einreise nach deutschland die
sicherheitsüberprüfung punkt stattfindet
und dann entsprechend auch feststellen
zu können die person schon in
deutschland war möglicherweise die
hierarchie mit einer wiedereinreise
sperre belegt ist und deshalb auch kein
rechts hat nach deutschland
zurückzukehren
[Musik]